der r&b-star treffen habe ich irgendwas
lassen sie das minister bleibe ich soll
mich also vielleicht doch von meiner
seite den leute bei mir zu schon jetzt
gerade worum es überhaupt geht ist ein
großes server projekt wo feedback ist
praktisch auf dem server drauf ist
gespielt nicht schon ganz freudig wir
spielen ein paar leute bzw auch einige
youtuber drauf und zwar in einem tollen
wechsel das heißt man darf hier nur
drauf spielen wenn man auch aufnimmt und
ich brauche jetzt eingeladen und ich
habe gemerkt wie man hat ja für so ein
bisschen eingesetzt würde ich mal sagen
danke dass du mich dann so noch mit
reingezogen hat nicht nur weil alle für
also der wasserbereich wir haben das
wirklich schöner konkret gesprochen da
bis jetzt nicht nur simon loben da kann
versuchen sie hatten ja dann
kontaktieren ich habe das ding so viel
mehr versprochen
danke ich knie nieder falls du dir sie
komisch aussicht ich danke weiterbauen
deswegen gehen wir zum grundstück wo ich
wohne ja ich ein schönes im pazifik sage
weil dieser folge die kommt bei mir am
samstagmittag das doch die einzige wenn
man jetzt was mit mir einfach halte ich
es kommt und heute abend kommt keine
folge sondern der live stream in dem es
fließt weiter spielen wir haben das
bisher aufgenommen jetzt einfach mal
vier mal schon erwähnt man drei mal
gesagt schlag bis zum boxen
durcheinanderreden banik sokolov für
sich der sache fünf leute ist echt ein
bisschen viel sonne und eben das habe
ich das lassen sie das ist okay ich
bleibe hier freilich die machen mich
auch gleich mal eine kleine rund führung
für das hinter uns haben und zwar wie
man energie hier erzeugt hat er mit dem
kopf
also das war nicht gekommen
ein stück mainz überspringt glaube ich
das war's durch ist es schon sehr schwer
ein jude grundstück ich bekomme so und
zwar wie man helfen kann
der turm wird noch wachsen ich habe hier
wenn ihr so reinschaut
ich habe hier bisher acht waters oder
vier gesetzt die durch wasser gebaut
werden ist die schwächste energiequelle
dies bewies eigentlich gibt aber dies
bestellen morgen endlich die sache story
so hast du nur eine
das kostet viel und ich wollte was noch
dazu bauen also kommt hier rein in der
regelfall dürft ihr nicht rein weil
kämpfer unterschlupf betreten verboten
aber ich öffne die tür wie heißt das wie
hat das seine potters caps und
buttermilch ganze technik also feuer
weiter geht
es gibt verschiedene sachen die es als
einmal jeder major lazer generator und
was weiß ich dass es gibt merkt euch das
denn wer in verwandelt ein renault in
zwei jahren das heißt das heißt hier
verdoppelte ärzten mit dem das zweite
ist ein extrakt oder damit im
verdreifacht ihr euer gummi das braucht
ihr auch sehr häufig und das dritte ist
ein elektrischer ofenwerk bisschen
besser also ein bisschen energie
effizienter ist aber die abo bevor sie
schon alles herten gefrorene seht ihr
eine bedburg und recht machen ja schon
40.000 energie gespeichert weil auch
wenn keiner online ist läuft dir die
energie der watermill es weiter wenn ich
hier oben ist auch noch eine blackbox
drin weil damit muss sein weil sonst das
wasser in kommt wäre cool und hier ist
ein generator das heißt wenn ich mein
lover einmal hinten und würde würde der
zusätzliche energie liefern falls ich
mal ein mega schub brauche was dies
alles angucken
das bei mir auch also das sind einfache
kräftige rezepte was ganz wichtig ist
was ihr euch merken müsste es gibt so
eine art im ranch das ist das hier so
eine art hier inbusschlüssel das sind
damit könnt ihr nur diese ganzen sachen
abbauen das spitzhacke bauen würde
würden die zu den ressourcen werden oder
kaputt gehen maximal ihren kaputten auto
ist gleich das gestellt die kostet
glaube ich 20 eisen oder so dass nur
doppelt gewarnt sein
was hast du da so konnte bis basic
service eingeben ich glaube die tutorial
hat mit 320 direkt auch schon
dann würde ich am anfang wir haben ein
grundstück machen müssen loslegen oder
seiten gibt noch was für ein anfang zu
klären
nur eigentlich nicht weitergehen und
stücke an schauen wir dass wir so eine
kleine spontane aufnahme ist von mir
sieht man will zeigen was du gemacht
hast ja komm mit ich habe mir ein
bisschen 0 so schönheits sachen gemacht
es hat noch keine elektronischen sachen
und zog sie klar wenn dann gleich mal
mit
also ich hab in meinem grundstück hier
so ein bisschen weg noch einmal
angepasst
hier ist es so weit kommt man rein dann
geht man einfach dadurch dass sie den
rucksack auf einen rucksack bald der
erweiterte das inventar oder einfach
eingehen backpack dann siehst du dir das
freudig hast du das nächste was ich
machen will ist ein jetpack anfliegen
neuerdings durch die gegend geprägt
wir haben so viel kaffee aber schon
besprochen wie du das machst so ich hab
da so unsere abmachung war kloster und
ich habe wirklich kommen wir heute
wissen dass bei mir ich bin 20 mal
gestorben oder so hat mein bett nehmen
cave oder so aufgestellt weil da bloß
noch eine falle getreten bin und das
misstrauen wasser halten ab geschwitzt
hier ein schreibt was eine halle nehme
ich da sind hierbei den ruinen da sind
immer müssen sie dort fand ich selber
war simon richtig labyrinthen sein baum
das ist ja ich habe immer meine ökorenta
ich würde in eine kiste ja als besonders
darin ein körper
du hast einfach der diamant ist von dir
wissen haben
ich hab schon welche geschenke aber es
wird das netz aber jetzt offiziell habt
ihr gesehen habt ihr den band geschenkt
weil sie haben gesagt gib kräftig ihr
mann aber wir haben die leute auch
gesagt weil ich habe gesagt ja ich werde
später alle ressourcen verteilen das
hambacher fest zu finden aber das waren
gleich fünf ärzte oder so du bist mit
mit ihr bin ich wieder fit
diamant ist fit aber dass meine 1
bekommen
dann doch lieber mal bei mir ansonsten
ich hab mir ist nichts geschenkt
der stimmt ja gut ist dann ja vielleicht
bald einer rundtour ja ich habe mein
kampf eigentlich am besten kann es
einfach arbeiten werden wenn keine
andere leute mitarbeiten das ist mir
bisher aufgefallen der bisher immer mit
andern aufgenommen ich bin fast keine so
vorangekommen
ich bin ja ich hab mir damals zeigen
oder ja kann sich der gerne zeigen und
dann macht dann auch danach ende aber
ich hab ja wir waren jetzt ich weiß wie
viel auf höhlentour und habe ein paar
sachen kannst gerne mal gleich mal meine
karriere hat sich hier die robert reid
auf gewinnt mich dafür jemanden mit
einem titel träumt man diesen ich guck
mal diese provokation hier bei seinem
grundstück werden die wand doch denken
setzt das laufen habe ich auch schon
gesehen offene provokation
ja sagt muss man auf wie nudeln knast
oder ich gehe mal erfolge noch ein
bisschen auf erkundungstour die halbe
folge und dann hundekämpfe ich bin heute
so server geträumt und den dreck neben
kritik muss man an die türen bei dir zu
suchen
ja die läuft hast du hast du angefangen
hast ja nicht hier
ok also ganz dick ölquelle oder hat hier
eine ölquelle
ich hab das einfach der eigentlich
musste wasser holt ach so weil nur ein
öl kann es ja auch wichtig in energie
verwandeln als fantastisch ok guck mal
kann es hier gang in die kirche kommen
dass ich glücklich gegen abstauben ich
hab mich da abend hingelegt einnahmen an
die videos schießen diesem einen ganzen
ostring als mal reingucken
also habt ihr geld sollte wenn ihr
wirklich die technik sachen sehen wollt
dann am besten schon mal vorbeischauen
gibt schon was zu sehen
aber denk dran muss gestehen ich habe
ein paar folgen im vorlauf kommen was
hat diese wird erst in ein paar tagen
kommen also in wirklich ein paar tagen
erst ja also mir kommt heute abend also
meine vollkommen heute heute wo ich
jetzt im live stream heute abend kommt
mein live stream als da gibt's dann auch
die technik welche kräfte beim raps
besucher unternimmt gerne als am samstag
zu abends sorgen start der live stream
und leute wenn jetzt eigentlich wirklich
bei ihm simon im livestream ihren gast
dort mit bus oder damit aufnehmen oder
halt irgendwie also irgendwie sollte man
muss nicht auf jeden fall auch sehen
dass
alter schwede kann sehr lange voll
gemacht ich glaube langsam werde ich im
chor der space im cargo-geschäft ich
weiß ich habe so viel zu tun und zu
erklären was ihr alles bringen ich habe
das laufen und verteilt kleine geschenke
und bei dice park mit einer ganz auf die
zuschauer beruhigen soll ist das
durcheinander ist nur rad war da wird zu
viel ich wollte was schenken wir sind
nicht gerade in einer von vier und ich
habe mich vielleicht ein bisschen zurück
ich bin mir sagen auch weg also ich mach
jetzt ende bleiben sie stehen
geschenke eingeschränkt man mich dort
wird über eine halbe stunde locker also
ich bin diesen stein hier sehr sexy das
diesmal mit bridgestone oder geburt ich
werde jetzt einfach ich wert war
die höhe packen und dann werde ich dir
mein haus einbauen und alles in form und
so das ist unglaublich da ist sagt ja
klar ich brauche nur etwas verwirrt auf
reichweiten verlängerer schön zu sehen
dass ich noch kein bett eines nachts
wird es geht zwar alle pendler die
endplatte deswegen bringt aber ich hatte
euch auf den weg für mich ich habe auch
nichts mehr scheiße das waren take that
box das ist ja lächerlich das kann die
blackrock
ich machte mir direkt jetzt in jetlag
bürger alter hast du nicht irgendwie
möhre oder in meiner kiste schon kommen
auch mitschnitte kürzt das ja ich aber
das ist mein job der hier auf meine
wünsche gelandet ja ich bin gerade in
ländlich ersten so ein bisschen ein
sorgt das für das genossen habe und so
weiter und so fort das immer ganz gut da
möchte ich meine ich hab was in essen
ich habe doppelt für dich ich glaube
erstens den größten mangel war oder ich
eigentlich war draußen software tiere
aber es ist aber jetzt folgt eine der
sichersten bändigen bleibt bestimmt ach
so du kannst du mal anschauen wie
schnell dieser elektrische offen geht
und wenn bayern hatte das selber in
feierbiest alles abgabe du hast das
schon fast allen mainstage ab der denon
also das ist ja so dass dieser generator
die anderen sachen antreibt allerdings
kannst du den generate anstatt mit der
wasserquelle diebe oben hast kannst du
dir doch einfach mit cola antreiben das
klare ja genau aber schau mal oben wie
wenig energie wasser eigentlich bin ich
schon gut über teilen wir nicht
anerkannte gehst und oben rechtsklick
auf die bedburg macht das ist eigentlich
wie langsam muss schon rein gehen aber
wenn du richtig was wenn du richtig
richtig viel wasser hass und richtig ja
dann ist immer als weg später auf solche
dinger machen das mit öfen die sind im
sekundentakt schmelzen wir 1 und 2 auf
einmal und solche sachen
das werde ich alles noch machen so hast
du noch hunger
als strafmaß auf seinem grundstück aber
auch bodentiefe bedingungen auf dem mars
sieht man wenn man über die grenzen
darüber kommt ja so ein bisschen höher
das ganze system stellt sozusagen
jetpack und dann weil ich die folge auch
schon zu ende
ich glaube ich wird extrem lang sonst
noch machen wenn ich sowas schnell aber
die nächste folge dich aufnehme leute
noch mal kurz das info ist mit meinem
neuen pcs heißt es wird mit live stream
livestream wenn man beim ihr seht dann
wird das eh nicht da sein weil ihr job
kraft dass wir später auch samstag
deswegen also leicht dem in der
beschreibung genau bahnhof switch lage
landen wir einen gefallen tun wenn ihr
irgendwelche vier redstone schenken habe
ich da nicht habt ihr wirklich nicht
alles erste mal auf tour auf erzfeind
uhr luca du hast vier redstone oder
nicht weil wenn du hast ich schenk dir
dafür zwei glos nun die brauchte für die
geglaubt nicht ich will ganz nach gucken
werden
mehr sie also eins kann ich sagen ich
hab noch gar nichts
da haben wird schon ist das geil ein
eisenerz in zwei jahren schmelzen nach
super noch mal diesen eisen das dann
eigentlich zu machen
ihr müsst einfach im open reichen
derzeit jedoch ein messer und ein ofen
dann beiden wichtigsten sachen weil so
verdoppelte jedes erz auch die aber wenn
ihr später das diktat schafft könnt ihr
sogar diamanten ärztin zwei diamanten
machen sowie ein redstone ärztin 12
redstone
ist das logisch wenn man sich dann
einfach eine spitzhacke verzaubert auf
glück club drei dann kriegt man
teilweise drei diamanten auf seinen
heraus
die arbeit eisenhaltigen
hundertprozentig sicher war gut aber die
pflückt drei euro abliefern möchte hat
jetzt irgendwer etwas von euch wirklich
aber wenn du am samstagabend ein eps in
möchtest und du denkst die fläche ist
mit den aufnahmen gebrüllt wenn du jetzt
nicht so viele aufnahmen vor oder voraus
drehen möchte vielleicht mache einfach
eine lange folge so dass wieder ein
pokémon dingen also nur sechs tore in
folge el sawija sind live die folge sein
gefolge wo ich beim letzten elfer oder
kriege ich hin keine hektar je nachdem
wie viel arbeit auf den musikstunden
folge nicht nur glücklich jetzt redstone
suche weil so geht mir der arsch auf
grundeis ich wollte die folge nicht im
so lange machen ich bau ne 4 redstone
das natürlich frei creating ganze
natürlich traurig als wir die auch
fragen was hier mache ich hole mir
geht's für getreide hast ja keiner von
euch eine getreide fahren oder dann hat
keiner der gastronomen gar nicht
eindeutig ich habe bald eine dann werde
ich wahrscheinlich auch getreide
verkaufen zu sagt es ist logisch
überlegt nach bmw spielst denkst du sie
sind logisch dass ich nicht ich hab nur
glaube ich gesehen wo ich die anfangs
folge sei es gestürmt
seid einfach ohne equipment los gestimmt
die ruinen hab gleich ein monster
besiegt er hatte nicht mal ein schwert
und er hat ist ein blinder na ja ich
werde auch mal ganz gut sagen ich wird
dann auch mal meine aufnahme werden ich
habe jetzt fünf folge aufgenommen davon
drei mit sub prime und um gespielt und
zwei so halb vier mit super gespielt und
eine noch mal mit sparc und kämpft
arbeiter haben wir wieder eine menge
whiskey damit major sachen kennt ihr
natürlich bei mir schon von den alten
titel wie sachen ich würde einfach sagen
es euch gefallen hat dürfte gerne ein
daumen hoch geben dann ist es jetzt auch
wieder so wenn ihr dieses video seht
müsste eigentlich gerade mittwoch sein
weil sie allerdings nicht genau ich bin
jetzt aus dem urlaub zurück und kann
wieder kommentare lesen neu aufnehmen am
mittwoch mit
dann kommen wieder folgen wo ich
wirklich auch auf eure kommentare
eingehen kann auf tipps eingehen kann
welcher noch alleine aufnehmen kann auch
mit fiete wies sachen beschäftigen und
blog würden mich bei spark ungespielt
pfefferspray hier ist bedanken dafür
dass sie hier dabei war dass sie mir das
als der kroate bla bla bla bla bla
woltering was sagen ich liebe dich ich
hab mir viel beigebracht hätte gar auf
die arena wiesbaden das war das
unglaublichste das mag vielleicht eine
bereicherung für meine komplette
aufnahme ein paar takten redstone in der
höhle beenden